bewilderment i think from conservative
mps as people try to navigate this
frankly constitutional crisis latest in
the last few moments is there are some
cabinet ministers i'm being told that
are currently trying to unresign get
back into their posts because it's so
uncertain whether boris johnson
continues for weeks or months with a
dominant rob or another caretaker comes
along what we also know is that there
are people very close to boris johnson
who are effectively trying to drop a
legacy for him he wants to do tax cuts
in however much long
in whatever uh in whatever form he can
in whatever time he has left but the
question sophie is what happens next and
we have some intelligence
uh this morning yougov uh conducted a uh
poll of conservative members the people
who are going to determine the next tory
leader and hence the next
conservative prime minister who will
succeed boris johnson and it has found
that in pole position the person who
would succeed boris johnson according to
this poll is ben wallace the defense
secretary ugov's tory members poll makes
clear that ben wallace beats liz trust
the foreign secretary penny mordent
rishi sunak who was chancellor uh and
jeremy hunt uh liz trust comes out
second uh penny mordent third and uh liz
trust and then jeremy hunt uh way below
clearly some of the dozen or so names uh
not in that poll nadim sahawi uh for
instance sawella braverman uh steve
baker weren't polled but ben wallace the
defense secretary who has been at boris
johnson's side all the way through is
coming out on top according to this tory
members poll he would beat liz trust by
48 of tory members to 29 percent who'd
vote for uh liz trust uh just above how
much he would beat penny mordant by uh
uh and uh rishi soon by a similar margin
as well this would be remarkable because
ben wallace he has been a longtime boris
johnson supporter he's earned his spurs
particularly uh not only through the
withdrawal of afghanistan but more
recently through his handling of ukraine
crisis he routinely comes out top of
other
membership service surveys particularly
the one by conservative home but here's
the thing sophie that would mean that
tory members who are overwhelmingly
brexit
actually are considering are happy to
consider a remainer to succeed boris
johnson that's a remarkable turnaround
that tells you quite a lot about where
the party is at the moment pushing down
brexit perhaps as a priority rising up
other issues such as statesmen like uh
leadership and an ability to uh engage
on the media those the kind of qualities
that ben wallace has been admired for by
tory mps uh and those are the kinds of
reasons uh that uh the membership might
be lining up behind ben wallace we're in
for a hell of a contest it's quite
possible that mps will have to whittle
down the field uh from the dozen or so
people like to stand down to the last
two candidates possibly even before the
summer recess in less than three weeks
but as it stands if those last two
candidates include ben wallace mps put
him through he beats pretty much any
other contender including those who've
been hard at it with behind the scenes
leadership campaigns for some time